Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Sag mal du bist ja schon wieder ganz weit weg in was für einem land bist du eigentlich gerade.
Das kann ich leider nicht sagen weil dann muss ich nachher bei der einreise in garantin.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertdreiunddreißig es schnaps bei zweiter märz zwanzig ist heute,
ja und ich ziehe mir mal schon mal einen mundschutz an.
Mailand oder madrid hauptsache italien.
Genau manche sind schon aufgefallen wir machen gerade so ein bisschen fernprogramm aber teilweise fällt es auch gar nicht mehr auf auch interessant zu sehen,
zu hören zu lesen.
Eigentlich gehört es ja zu meinem persönlichen stolz dass wir mit sicherheit der podcast sind der,
die meisten also wenn man sendeminuten mal distanz nimmt dann haben wir sicherlich den höchsten wert.
Von von alle von alle aber man stolz schmeißt sich eigentlich daraus dass man das nicht hört.
Schießen die spekulationen ins kraut ja aber es ist so teilweise manchmal ist es so manchmal.
Aber jetzt hört man es ein bisschen schon also ich bin mit dem dieses mal also auf das equipment auf der sich hier jetzt dieses mal sätze möchte ich dich nochmal setzen.
Jedes mal anders.
Diese eine sendung vorletzte da die ging so nicht das kann man so nicht machen da muss investiert werden also spendet immer geld.
Aber das auch untergebracht gehört jetzt zum podcast dazu.
Heutzutage.
Podcast.
Immer schön klingelbeutel pudern.
So dann kommen wir zum feedback oder oder musst du noch nur so musst du noch irgendwas sagen.
Ich spare mir die witze für später auf.
Okay dann dann so viel haben wir auch nicht.
Nee.
Okay dann dann darfst du den weg beginnt music.
Genau da wart ihr dann so nett und habt alle schön träume gleich wieder zur zerstört ich berichtete ja von dieser witzige idee doch einfach mal alle melodien,
auf platte zu per mutieren mit einem algorithmus und dann wurde alles gut werden.
Da haben wir dann einen kommentar von quickcap easy noch eine anmerkung zu all the music zumindest aus sicht des,
deutschen beziehungsweise kontinental europäischen urheberrechts beruht diese aktion auf einem grundlegenden missverständnis ein urheberrecht erwirbt man nicht indem man ein werk als erster erfindet sein indem man es in einem schöpferischen prozess hervorbringt
anders als im patent recht kann man das auch mehrfach passieren wenn zwei leute tatsächlich unabhängig voneinander das gleiche werk schaffen sind beide urheber
ohne dass sie gegeneinander ansprüche hätten ob das nach anderen urheberrecht system,
inklusive us copyright prinzipiell anders ist kann ich nicht beurteilen man kann aber wohl realistischerweise ausschließen dass dieser hack in irgendeinem rechtssystem auswirkungen hat,
ja
Ja ja.
Kann sein einem notar der mensch der das gemacht hat ist ja auch selber loyal also von daher denke ich mal nicht dass das jetzt einfach nur so eine grille ist
und am ende ist ja gerade die definition was ist denn ein schöpferischen prozess ja also ein schöpferische prozess ist es auch ein programm zu schreiben.
Also ich will das jetzt nicht gleich tot sagen aber es,
liebe zur kenntnis dass es hier durchaus die spezifisch europäische perspektive gibt die sagten vielleicht auch nicht.
Markus komba twitterte dazu irgendwie auch in deutschland sind nur persönlich geistige schöpfungen schutz war das ist bei schöpfung durch algorithmus nicht der fall dann bin ich mal gespannt weil.
So wieder wild aber dann dann dann heißt das ja dass er den gesamten.
Zukünftige schaffung was alles irgendwie durch algorithmen entwickelt wird und so nicht mehr schützbar ist da muss er schon nochmal jemand bei,
also ich glaube ehrlich gesagt auch nicht deswegen dieses musical jetzt das thema feld aber lustig ist es dennoch.
Ja aber ich meine das ist das ist doch wirklich du kannst ja dann auch das umdrehen und sagen wenn du ein algorithmus entwickelt hast um deine melodien zu machen ist die nicht mehr schützbar.
Genau da.
Und das ist ja auch humbug so also das das
also da würde ich sagen ist jetzt der drops nicht final abgeleckt sondern dass dass dass es wirklich viel definitionssache frage und man könnte ja noch sehr viel weiter weil es gibt ja eine ganze menge
tools die einem sozusagen per algorithmus da was machen so und dann hört man sich an und wenn man die
dann gut findet dann dann dann ist es irgendwie eine schöpferische leistung also ich meine da kann ich mir auch alle melodien anhören und sagen fand ich fand ich jetzt alle ziemlich gut,
so wieder auf der platte sind also ich habe mich ja alle durchgehört alle super kam mir gleich so vor als hätte ich die erfunden.
Hallo.
Schöpferische leistung na ja ich meine wo ist jetzt der unterschied wenn ich jetzt irgendein plugin in einem logik starte,
was mir so ein melody perlmut a rauswirft so nach dem motto wird mir einfach mal paar randale melodien vor und dann finde ich die gut,
muss ich jetzt irgendwie jede note mit der maus selber gesetzt haben und hin und her geschoben haben bevor es dann ist wie will man das dann nachweisen dass es so ist also es ist einfach irgendwo,
schwierig.
Tim du weißt dass dadurch nach dass du bei einem einer der großen etablierten veröffentlichung label institutionen das veröffentlicht und damit bei der gema dann ein anmeldest.
Ich nicht nicht man muss das nicht bei der gema anmelden das hast du falsch verstanden wenn er geh mal ist man ist generell alles erstmal geschützt so da muss man gar nichts anmelden das ist ja das ding anmelden müssen nur die leute die es nutzen müssen.
Ja geh mal hatten wir auch schon mal eine sendung zu können wir darauf verweisen.
Wir haben auch noch feedback bekommen zu assange und roger stone wir haben ja.
Zum wiederholten male in der letzten sendung versucht nochmal so diese league geschichte ein bisschen über die jahre zusammenzufassen.
Und haben am rande auch erwähnt dass roger stone ja verurteilt wurde und da kommentiert simon,
beziehungsweise und in dem zusammenhang haben wir noch darüber gesprochen dass.
Im justizministerium ja quasi gegen die staatsanwälte darf,
entschieden wurde oder die quasi dienstanweisung bekommen haben nicht so ein hohes strafmaß zu fordern die richterin aber am ende ein noch niedrigeres geurteilt hat und das kommentiert simon die richterin die das strafmaß für roger stone geurteilt hat muss übrigens nicht so schnell um ihren job fürchten
wenn sie nicht in trumps sinne urteilt denn bundesrechts drinnen werden in den usa auf lebenszeit berufen und müssen durch den senat,
per impeachment abgerufen werden ich glaube nicht dass da die beeinflussung für dieses verfahren am ende ausschlaggebend war,
danke für den hinweis hatten wir so nicht auf dem schirm das heim haben uns mehrere darauf hingewiesen unter anderem auch andreas der darüber hinaus sagte.
Denn die republikaner monieren neben dem strafmaß das die jury nicht unparteiisch gewesen sei
weil sich die vorsitzende der jury auf den sozialen medien geäußert hat
und dort zuvor den demokraten freundlich gesinnte positionen vertreten hatte die richterin hat die gesamte jury trotzdem gelobt und kein misstrauen erklärt ja also diese jury geschichten das ist ja auch wirklich ein.
Ich weiß auch nicht was ich davon halten soll irgendwie bei solchen gerichtsverfahren auf eine jury zu setzen irgendwelche laichen die da sitzen gerade bei so höchst aufgeladenen davon auszugehen dass die nicht in irgendeiner form,
also dass die empathie sein können halte ich für sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Und der weiterhin sagt andreas zu roger stone er hat nicht nur für sondern mit paul manafort gearbeitet als einer der namensgebenden partner in ihrer politischen berater gesellschaft diese war vorräte der des sumpf
den trump angeblich austrocknen will und hat unter anderem eine reihe diktatoren vertreten und ihnen geholfen ihr image in den usa aufzupolieren.
Das ist ja übrigens auch generell wenn man sich da mal so diese trump umgebung anschaut ein ein offensichtlich sehr beliebtes geschäftsmodell auch rudy giuliani ja der da so als etwas irrlicht in.
Aber nicht mein wenn man sich den anguckt dass der was mit image aufzupolieren zu tun.
Ja aber das das ist sagen wir mal so ein bisschen der der der ex-club den man da im,
us-amerikanischen establishment mal ebenfalls vor hervorheben kann.
Denn all diese ganzen verhältnisse in die ukraine etcetera sind teilweise halt auch nichts anderes gewesen als das dass da einfach irgendwelche leute,
wollen dass sie quasi in den usa gesellschaftsfähig werden.
Und dann kümmern sich dann eben diese unternehmen unter anderem eben das von rudy giuliani darum sozusagen diese leute dann in kontakt,
zu bringen oder irgendwelche berichte über die zu lancieren
um die sozusagen da in einem guten licht stehen zu lassen so ja hier hat geschäftsbeziehungen zu x und so weiter um den dann sozusagen ein einfallstor für weitere wirtschaftliche connections zu machen das ist mehrfach
belegt und das scheint hier sehr beliebt zu sein und das sind dann halt gerade die verbindung nach russland und in die ukraine sehr vielseitig wo also einfach leute die dort zu einer menge geld gekommen sind eben gerne eine lage versetzt werden,
sollen da in den usa halt mit dem geld auch etwas anzufangen ja genau dass man da einfach irgendwie mit mit der kohle auch mal was bewirken kann,
so läuft da der hase und deswegen sind auch diese ganzen verbindungen im nicht weiter überrascht man fragt sich ja die ganze zeit was
was haben die einfach die ganze zeit so mit russland ukraine so ja das ist einfach die große nachfrage des dort durch sonstige ausbeutung gewonnenen geldes was eben gerne in den westen kommen möchte.
So t kreische wurst hat auch noch kommentiert.
Ja genau und zwar haben wir kommentare bekommen zu chelsea menning und unseren,
ausführungen dazu meint ball begnadigung würde man eher an paraden denken,
präsident obama hatte mannings haftstrafe allerdings nur computer das heißt die strafe,
geändert sodass menning nur noch ein paar monate anstatt ein paar jahren absetzen musste ich bin mir selber nicht ganz sicher wie das rechtlich detail,
wie man das rechtlich unterscheidet ich meine aber dass man bei einem paar denn,
also bei einer richtigen begnadigung zwar nicht als unschuldig gesehen wird viele den negativen effekte einer verurteilung aberkennung des wahlrechts et cetera
allerdings wieder aufgehoben werden bei einer communication wird nur die strafe beziehungsweise das strafmaß geändert,
also lebenslang statt todesstrafe oder halt fünf statt fünfunddreißig jahre et cetera.
Den fehler hatte ich glaube ich gemacht dass ich gesagt habe dass hier ein paten kurz vor der amtszeit bekommen hat,
was ja das ziel der damaligen kampagne war aber ja communication of the center hundertprozentig richtig von t kreisvorstand das ist doch kein name für ein kind.
Dann.
Dann haben wir noch auch zu männlich ein kommentar von andrea.
Zuerst möchte ich euch mal danken wegen eurer herausragenden unterstützung von schatzi manning über wenn ich mich nicht irre die zurückliegenden zehn jahre ich habe schon viel stunden auch die wikipedia und das internet durchforstet,
wenn ich aber,
nun zum schluss mit mir allein die ergebnisse anschaue die ich irgendwie auch durch google bekomme dann neben chelsea manning und schulen sorge ab.
Und edward snowden greenworld irgendwie bisschen mehr zu.
Aber insgesamt eigentlich höre ich finde ich am meisten zu den drei männern und wenig zu chelsea elizabeth menning sodass ich den,
eindruck habe dass sie öffentlich zu wenig gewürdigt wird deshalb möchte ich euch fragen kommt das nur mir so vor.
Nee den den eindruck hab ich auch jetzt ist die frage also muss sie noch gewürdigt werden sie geht also letztendlich.
Versucht sie jetzt einfach ein leben zu führen hat sich der politisch irgendwie in stellung gebracht da ist glaube ich nicht bisher noch nicht so viel draus geworden unter anderem weil sie jetzt ja auch wieder irgendwie im knast sitzt in beugehaft.
Und das finde ich deswegen fand ich das wort gewürdigt da vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt das richtige ihre situation wird irgendwie nicht wahrgenommen die ist jetzt seit ewigkeiten in beugehaft mit diesem,
skurrilen system wo sie jetzt auch noch selber bezahlen muss und darüber wird nicht so wirklich berichtet.
Einfach auch weil es da nichts neues zu berichten gibt außer dass sie halt in der der geldbetrag den sie irgendwie schuldet mit jedem tag in beugehaft zunimmt und dass sie sich halt weiterhin da wert vor dieser,
grandios auszusagen da ist auf jeden fall jeder aufmerksamkeit und jede unterstützung,
notwendig und gut angebracht ja da werden ja nochmal gleich auf auch eingehen.
Es ist schon sehr erstaunlich was sie da mit ihr machen denn,
tatsächlich ist ihr bezug zu dem assange thema sehr brüchig und sie ist ja ich meine sie ist ja für den gesamten fall und alles was sie da getan hat und zu tun hat wurde sie ja.
Hat sie ja vor gericht gestanden also es ist sehr unsinnig eigentlich von ihr noch mehr zu verlangen.
Und ja dafür für dieses unrecht was ihr da eigentlich die ganze zeit geschieht dafür kriegt sie viel zu wenig aufmerksamkeit und viel zu wenig,
würdigung aber so ist das leider auch ein bisschen mit leuten über die halt dann einmal ein urteil gesprochen wurde diese nicht würdigung von chelsea manning,
ich hatte jetzt auch nicht den eindruck dass irgendwie weltweit besonders davon ausgegangen ist dass ihre verurteilung irgendwie ein.
Ein besonderer skandal oder besonders problem gewesen wäre so das war irgendwie fanden alle glaube ich ganz in ordnung so also hat jetzt niemand gesagt
hier die hat kriegsverbrechen aufgedeckt und so wird im militärgericht verurteilt und drakonischer strafen und so weiter das hat auch damals keine so große rolle gespielt also wenn man.
Als macht habende in der gesellschaft erstmal die leute,
hat und die weg und die verurteilt dann hat ja diese.
Dieses vertrauen dass wir als bürgerinnen und bürger in den rechtsstaat und in die verfahren haben auch zur folge dass man dann sagt naja wurde schon nicht ohne grund verurteilt ne.
Wird schon was dran sein ja.
Wird schon was dran sein ne oder wenn der irgendwie weiß ich nicht wie lange der jetzt schon irgendwie
wurde ja und das ist schon alles okay so wenn wenn das dann wenn wenn man den gerichten hinzugeführt wurde dann läuft es da auch alles in ordnung scheint so der einblick zu sein darauf deswegen gehen wir gleich auch nochmal auf das gerichtsverfahren.
Gegen julian assange ein also kurz um nee kommt nicht nur die sofort.
So dann hat sich irgendjemand noch versprochen hast du das.
Donald trump hat sich versprochen wird doch nicht geheimdienst koordinator der bleibt in berlin vertan.
Klar natürlich total sowas macht man ja auch mal eben mal.
Das erinnert mich ja dieses schöne lied von von helge schneider.
Welches.
Ich habe mich vertan sehr schönes lied ja also bleibt uns doch erhalten er ist also da kann man jetzt auch kurz den.
Punkt erklären also er ist ja interims geheimdienst koordinator und dann wollte trump,
sagen dass er einen neuen.
Geheimdienst koordinator finden wird und hat dann aber gesagt ich werde einen neuen botschafter für deutschland ernennen und ja dann,
es ist halt schwierig wenn man so oft wie der leute feuert und er nennt und,
was er da alles auch für verrückte positionen hatten sowas wie geheimdienst koordinator oder botschaft in botschafter nach deutschland ist ja auch okay dass man da mal durcheinander kommt.
Die wahrheit ist wohl die idee ihn wirklich zum geheimdienst koordinator zu machen kam nicht so richtig gut an bei den geheimdiensten und er musste wieder zurückrudern.
Hat er sich verteilt so dann gab's noch eine sehr interessante meldung im.
Nachgang zu hanau.
Denn in seinem manifest und in seinen videos erwähnt der täter von hanau der mörder der ja.
Insgesamt elf menschen getötet hat inklusive sich selber und seiner mutter was der.
Soll sich bereits kurz nach der jahrtausendwende mit strafanzeigen an verfolgungs- behörden gewandt haben das sagt er auch ja sagte ich habe hier zweitausendzwei und zweitausendvier strafanzeigen gestellt gegen diesen,
namenlosen geheimdienst wegen illegaler überwachung geh,
also entgegen seiner erwartungen und setze seinem unmut wurden diese anzeigen aber wohl nicht ernst genommen und.
Jetzt kommt aber raus der hat sich auch im november letzten jahres an den generalbundesanwalt gewandt und das schreiben was er dort verfasst hat
neunzehn seitig ist in weiten teilen identisch mit seinem manifest das heißt er hat irgendwie ein größeren teil seiner gedanken da schon dem generalbundesanwalt geschickt,
und jetzt müssen sie sich natürlich fragen gefallen lassen so
kollegin wenn der wenn der euch sogar schreibt warum seid ihr dem nicht nachgegangen und.
Da würde ich jetzt mal vorsichtig anmerken,
dass das nicht der einzige irre gewesen sein wird der sich zwischen zweitausendzwei und zweitausendneunzehn an polizei und generalbundesanwalt gewendet hat.
Aber die frage die sich dann stellt wie konnte der in den besitz einer,
waffenbesitzkarte kommen wenn der letztendlich bei polizeibehörden aktenkundig ist weil er von von geheimen mächten überwacht wird und naja,
dann irgendwie im generalbundesanwalt da irgendwelche viren sachen schreibt da würde man ja dann schon erwarten dass da vielleicht mal einen background check oder sonstiges gemacht wird und man feststellt oh der typ.
Hat sehr interessante vorstellungen und zwei pistolen.
Naja vor allem mit so einem schrieb solltest du einfach sofort auf die
kriegt keine waffe und wenn er eine hat nehmen wir sie ihm weg liste geraten
dafür ist das waffengesetz ja nun extra geändert worden vielleicht auch nicht alle mitbekommen das ist jetzt sozusagen immer noch einmal durch den verfassungsschutz durchgeht wenn man eine waffe beantragt und wenn man da irgendwie auffällig geworden ist dann,
so ist zumindest der eigentlich gedachte modus scheint bloß noch nicht so richtig zu funktionieren wie konnten die konnte das nur passieren.
Tja dann hatten wir noch in der letzten sendung das thema passwort herausgabe,
mit diesem gesetz gegen den hass im internet und,
da hat sich jetzt jemand zu wort gemeldet den ich bis dahin nicht auf dem schirm hatte der ist hat es irgendwie weitgehend unbemerkt von der öffentlichkeit geschafft als kandidat der spd.
In den rechtsausschuss zu kommen mit achtunddreißig jahren und hat dann gemeint es wäre eine gute idee dem fokus ein interview zu geben,
und da sagt er die polizei sollte kinderpornos und terrorverdächtige zukünftig
zwingen dürfen ihnen das passwort für ihr onlinekonto ausgehändigten auf diese weise können ermittler die internet konnten der betroffenen übernehmen in deren rolle schlüpfen und so die hoch kriminellen kontaktleute sowie anbieter überführen,
florian post heißt er übrigens lieber florian oder soll ich floh sagen lieber flo,
es gibt einen unterschied zwischen verdächtigen und tätern und.
Irgendwie verdächtige zu zwingen dass sie passwörter herausgeben müssen ist so eine sache die eigentlich so schon vom grundgesetz her nicht unbedingt vorgesehen ist.
Des weiteren,
geht er dann auch noch spezifisch auf dieses gesetz gegen hass hassrede oder nimmt er dann noch zu diesem zu dieser passwort herausgabe beim gesetz gegen hassrede,
bezug wir erinnern uns da geht es
um die automatische meldung und übermittlung im verdachtsfall durch die online-plattform na also es geht nicht darum dass irgendwie eine richterin urteilt dass jetzt mein passwort in diesem verfahren herausgegeben werden muss oder so sondern es geht darum
dass irgendjemand ein kommentar in soziales netzwerk schreibt das unter umständen hassrede ist dass mit,
oder illegale inhalt das mit passwort und sämtlichen bestandsdaten und quasi dann zugriff auf das konto automatisiert an das bka gemeldet wird und die gehen davon aus dass sie zweihundertfünfzigtausend fälle pro jahr damit haben ja und
da hat noch keine richter draufgeschaut sondern die die online-plattform war dazu verpflichtet.
Und weiterhin eben hier geht's um um hassrede also viel weniger schwere vergehen als dokumentierten kindesmissbrauch da gab es übrigens auch wieder.
Gibt es häufig den hinweis der auch immer korrekt ist kinderpornografie ist natürlich ein euphemistisch optimistischer begriff wir reden hier letztendlich von dokumentierten kindesmissbrauch der da auch stattfindet ja also das schwere vergehen,
dokumentiert.
So da sagt er ist jetzt zitiere ich aus fokus ja ich war auf focus de ich musste halt ein paar sperren aufheben geradezu hirnrissig nennt
der spd-politiker diese argumentation wenn es nach einigen bedenkenträgern ginge dürften wir nur brieftauben trauben abfangen das ist wirklich kein normal denkenden
bürger mehr erklärbar wenn es hart auf hart kommt halte ich auch eine beugehaft von bis zu sechs monaten für absolut vertretbar
allerdings nur bei schweren straftaten und unter vorbehalt einer richtigen entscheidung ja florian post vielen dank.
Spannend wer also dass das so was hätte man ja eigentlich nur von der csu erwartet aber der typ kommt glaube ich auch aus münchen insofern kann man hier unter umständen,
mildernde umstände geltend machen aber mit so einer spd frage mich auch ernsthaft wie wir da noch naja.
Also also ich weiß nicht ob er mittlerweile in münchen ist er vertritt in münchner wahlkreis nord mittlerweile stimmt es allerdings aus der oberpfalz.
Was vielleicht jetzt keinen großen unterschied ausmacht aber naja.
Keine mildernde umstände.
Ja ja also damit kann man auf jeden fall nicht so gut an also für uns ist der glaube ich noch so ein bisschen neu ne hast du ja schon anklingen lassen der hat dir bis dahin auch nichts gesagt ich habe den namen,
auch noch nicht so gehört scheint wohl so ein vertrauter von sigmar gabriel zu sein keine ahnung,
wie der sich da so positionieren soll aber es ist irgendwie immer dieses das verstehen die bürger nicht wenn wir nicht mit einfachen parolen auftreten ja okay so kann man natürlich argumentieren aber,
dann versteht's halt das bundesverfassungsgericht nicht was du da sagst.
Es ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen.
Also die über dieses thema dann versteht's der bürger nicht oder sowas ne und das ist natürlich ein größeres problem in einer,
zeit in der sämtliche debatten irgendwie vereinfacht verkürzt und zugespitzt werden und es nur noch irgendwie um fundamentale breitseiten geht und irgendwie sämtlicher diskurs auch so ein bisschen
abhanden und verloren gekommen gegangen ist und deswegen ist das halt schwierig wenn menschen,
inklusive parlamentarier halt auf seine weise sprechen die jetzt auch wirklich den stammtisch noch unterbietet ja also hirnrissig ist einfach kein kein begriff,
der in so einem kontext feilen sollte.
Irgendwie weiß ich auch nicht versucht sich da gerade irgendwie in stellung zu bringen schauen wir mal was da noch so kommt aus bayern.
Okay dann bleiben wir aber erstmal oder komm jetzt erstmal zu unserem hauptthema nämlich julian assange.
Auslieferungs verfahren in.
England also es geht um die auslieferung an die usa wegen der vergehen über die wir in den,
in vielen sendungen gesprochen haben aber die wir insbesondere in der letzten sendung nochmal zusammengefasst haben und da gibt es jetzt echt sehr interessante berichte von den leuten,
die sich dieses verfahren,
anschauen von der besucher bank das sind nicht so viele wenn ich das jetzt recht in erinnerung habe gibt's da irgendwie sechzehn plätze oder so auf der besucher bank.
Und da sind interessante berichte kommen davon crack merry und von wenn ich mich nicht täusche arm ist dem jetzt fällt mir der name nicht ein ich muss schnell schauen,
hat auf dem kongress vorgetragen der büroleiter wahrscheinlich von martin sonneborn.
Steht der name hier irgendwo,
ja genau das sind das denn hoffnung der heißt wie der typ aus dem aus dem fernsehen und der ist tatsächlich jetzt in seiner rolle als leiter des büros sonneborn,
in england und beobachtet diesen oder hat diesen prozess beobachtet hat er davon berichtet genauso wie crack mary und was man da so liest was da abgeht das ist wirklich sehr interessant.
Was ein was geht denn also ab.
Also erstmal.
Es geht ja jetzt um die auslieferung nein es geht nicht darum ob der assange schuldig ist oder was auch immer sondern es geht erst mal darum welche art von verfahren ihm in groß in den usa gemacht werden soll.
Ob die ob das vereinigte königreich dorthin ausliefert spoiler alert wahrscheinlich schon ja.
Das findet statt.
Im wohlwert crown court wo der bell marsch magistrats court sich befindet ein gebäude,
das gebaut wurde um die öffentlichkeit rauszuhalten also eigentlich für terrorprozess und,
sehr interessant so von diesem was crack memory dann eben schreibt normalerweise wenn du in so einem gericht bist.
Dann soll da quasi da auch repräsentiert werden dass du gerade vor der öffentlichkeit stehst mit dem urteil welches du empfängst und so weiter.
Und er sagt dieses gesamte gebäude ist nichts als die physikalische negation der grundannahme der,
der unschuld der oder der nichts als außer der physikalischen negation.
Der unschuldsvermutung die inkarnation der ungerechtigkeit in stahl und beton und panzerglas.
Und ähnlich guantanamo in seiner rechts rechtsstaatlichkeit und.
Er sagt glaube ich auch so das ganze gebäude strahlt aus hier bist du nur weil du schuldig bist ja ist nicht irgendwie mehr so dass du dass das jetzt irgendwie ein gericht ist wo irgendwie noch gefaltet wird und geprüft wird.
Also mehr so destroy als amtsgericht.
Auf jeden fall und jetzt kommt aber das spannende jetzt sagt er auslieferung.
Werden immer vom westminster magistrat court verhandelt,
weil die auslieferungs ersuchen an die regierung in westminster gestellt werden und dieser westminster material fit court,
verhandelt auch nur eben in diesem hochsicherheitsgefängnis von bell marsch das heißt sie haben dieses auslieferungs verfahren in den terror trakt verlegt.
So behandeln sie da eben auch den assange der sich nämlich.
Hinter panzerglas befindet der lebt der ist da in einem in einer in einer box aus panzerglas wo du normalerweise halt,
gemein gefährliche terroristen reintust wo du angst haben muss dass sie was weiß ich noch irgendwie beißen oder sowas ne.
Also da gehört nämlich dann auch gleich noch ein hochsicherheitsgefängnis dazu was eben direkt an diesen court angeschlossen ist es bell marsch.
Herr majestic prison bell marsch.
Ja ja na klar es ist einfach alles sehr royal ne also selbst selbst wenn du das scheiß behandelt wird und vollkommen deiner freiheiten legt bist kannst du dich zumindest darin freuen dass das alles irgendwie sehr royal ist,
ohne ohne ohne käse natürlich ne royal ohne käse.
Mit dem käse weise nicht so genau ich habe den eindruck da gab es dann doch noch doppelt käse in der verhandlung.
Das problem ist also es wird geschildert die akustik in diesem gebäude ist ein albtraum also von der besuchertribüne ist es schwer da die leute zu verstehen und wenn die mal nicht genau ins mikrofon sprechen,
hörst du sie garantiert nicht mehr und der assange sagt halt ich kann,
dem geschehen hier nicht folgen weil ich kann nur wenig sehen und ich kann auch nicht gut hören und sagt natürlich er würde gerne bei seinen anwälten sitzen wie jeder normale mensch.
Gerade julian assange ist jetzt nicht jemand der von dem jetzt zu erwarten ist dass der da irgendwie eine krasse aktion jetzt irgendwie durch finden irgendwie gewalttätig würde oder sowas.
Er sitzt in diesem glas käfig auch hinter seinem anwälten was zur folge hat wenn die die richterin adressieren.
Oder ich glaube du musst ja ich weiß gar nicht ob sie die krone adressieren müssen oder.
Das gericht wahrscheinlich dürfen wir das gericht adressieren die krone ist nur irgendwie auch dabei.
Und die müssen natürlich wenn jetzt da der der der anwalt argumentiert muss ja natürlich die richterin angucken und der assange ist aber hinter ihm und was dazu führt dass.
Wenn der song jetzt mal irgendwie so eine einwände und eine anmerkung oder einen tipp irgendwie oder so übrigens denk auch mal daran zu seinem anwalt sagen möchte,
dann muss der winken und die leute auf der suche besuchertribüne sehen dass der assange winkt,
dann winken die leute auf der besuchertribüne dem anwalt zu und wenn der das mitbekommt und nicht zu genau auf die richterin guckt.
Dann wird er irgendwann darauf aufmerksam dass der assange ihm vor fünf minuten was sagen wollte.
Aber kann er denn überhaupt mit denen sprechen wenn er nochmal panzerglas dazwischen ist.
Da ist wohl irgendwie so ein da muss ein schlitz auch in dem glas sein weil eine situation geschildert wird wo der anwalt ihm irgendwie die hand reichen möchte zur verabschiedung.
Und sofort das sicherheitspersonal was auch in diesem glas käfig von dem assange ist dazwischen geht und damit hat er natürlich auch keinen vertrauens möglichkeiten zu seinem zu seinem anwalt zu sprechen und.
Jetzt geht dieses verfahren los und der.
Chefankläger ist quasi james louis der da seine ansprache richtet,
und primär hauptsächlich darüber redet dass.
Und eben nicht so sei dass wenn man nun julian assange ausliefert beziehungsweise verurteilt dass das gleich so wäre für einen gleichbedeutend wäre mit der abteilung eines journalisten.
Interessant ist dass er seine äußerung sogar nochmal wiederholt so wichtige äußerung wiederholt zum mitschreiben für die medien,
obwohl er eigentlich mit dem gericht zu reden hat also der stellt sich quasi dahin und sagt ich wiederhole diesen wichtigen satz jetzt noch einmal damit die medienvertreter das auch richtig mitschreiben können nicht sehr geil wenn du so vor gericht
redest so hey
entschuldigung liebe richterin kann ich das kann ich mich nochmal kurz wiederholen für insta oder so da wird es ja auch irgendwie ein auch für mappe.
Ja und vor allem seine aussage ist dann im wesentlichen die ja liebe journalisten zum mit meißeln bitte einmal er ist kein journalist wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Genau und.
Er sagt es sei nämlich nicht für das veröffentlichen der capes sondern für das veröffentlichen der namen angeklagt,
und dafür menning beim hacking geholfen zu haben,
dann verließ er vor gericht irgendwie medien artikel die kritisch zu assange sind und will also sehr eindeutig in seinem opening statement einen keil zwischen den medien und assange treiben und das ist,
vor dem hintergrund interessant dass.
Also selbst die richterin sagt dann irgendwann mal so naja moment mal also wenn so argumentiert dann müsste das doch auch für für alle medien gelten und dann wird er gerät der irgendwie ins rudern,
und schließt dann damit dass außerdem menschenrechte und meinungsfreiheit in auslieferungs verfahren ohnehin irrelevant sein auch das eine sagen wir mal rechts einschätzung die jetzt nicht von allen gelehrten,
geteilt wird das spannende ist muss man nochmal kurz sagen die veröffentlichung der namen.
Von denen hier die rede ist als diese cambrills.
Veröffentlicht wurden wurden sie ja sehr stark redakteur veröffentlicht also es waren monatelange arbeit da alle namen von informanten innen kollaborateure drinnen und so weiter.
Zu schmerzen damit man jetzt leute die was weiß ich in afghanistan mit der zusammenarbeiten oder informationen an die amerikaner geben nicht in lebensgefahr bringt und.
Jetzt war es so dass in der in der anbahnung der zusammenarbeit mit dem guardian.
Hat der assange natürlich den nicht.
Nicht redaktionell überarbeiteten teil also die rohen cambrills dem guardian zukommen lassen müssen denn diese überarbeitung fand ja erst später statt.
In zusammenarbeit mit dem guardian also hat er eine verschlüsselte datei angefertigt,
und wenn ich das recht erinnere mit der mit der hilfe von einfach symmetrisch verschlüsselt mit einem passwort und,
diesen link dann dem guardian journalisten zu.
Kommen lassen wenn ich mich nicht täusche war das luke harding da müsste ich aber nochmal gucken es kann auch sein dass das ein anderer journalist war und ich den namen gerade durcheinander bringe jetzt passiert folgendes,
wikileaks zu dieser zeit schon kontrovers stand immer wieder unter die night of service angriffen.
Und die haben dann anleitungen verteilt wie man quasi wikileaks mirror kann.
Und haben dazu aufgerufen die inhalte von wikileaks zu mir ran damit sie zugreifbar bleiben.
Weil sie das in einer gemacht haben haben sie einfach sämtliche server inhalte mirror lassen inklusive dieser großen verschlüsselten datei mit diesen daten drin jetzt.
Geht ich glaube gar nicht so viel später.
Dieser journalist hin und veröffentlicht ein buch indem er das alles schildert.
Wie die zusammenarbeit mit wikileaks war und so weiter ne hast jetzt irgendwie ich meine du hast eine
großartige politische story mit wikileaks und so hast du eine spannende zusammenarbeit also wurde dann ein,
buch darüber veröffentlicht wenn ich mich nicht täusche hieß das buch wikileaks insight julian assange war und aus dem dann auch der film der pfiff state wurde und,
jedenfalls wurde in diesem buch von dem ich rede ein buch kapitel betitelt.
Mit dem passwort mit dem der assange diese datei verschlüsselt hatte.
Und das war nämlich der diplomatie history of the world from nine six till present oder sowas das war das passwort.
Und jetzt hattest du diese datei.
Auf x mirror und ich glaube das wurde per toren verteilt und das passwort dazu.
In einem in einem buch stehen und.
Mit der veröffentlichung dieses buches war es dann eigentlich assange der das gesehen hat.
Und unmittelbar sogar das ich glaube die us-regierung ich weiß nicht ob das die oder das außenministerium quasi angerufen hat und gesagt hat hey leute,
das ist hier was gerade passiert ist ist ein desaster mit der veröffentlichung dieses buches wird es nicht mehr lange dauern bis.
Bis leute eben diese gesamten daten in ruhe haben ihr habt hier eine krise und die.
Genau das wird aber jetzt assange zum zur last gelegt.
Das da nämlich die namen veröffentlicht worden sein weil sie versuchen ihm diesen.
Mithilfe da anzuhängen.
Oh man ey ich ich erinnere mich noch an diese geschichte mit dem passwort was ich mich nicht mehr erinnere ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt in deine notizen ist.
Er hat das bewusst als als titel gewählt weil es das passwort war und auch darauf hingewiesen dass das das passwort dieser datei war in der annahme dass niemand sonst diese datei hatte.
So als stilmittel sozusagen ne.
Das steht sogar in dem buch drin das ist nämlich irgendwie dass der association irgendwie sagt dass der assange auf einen zettel schreibt history of the world und dann sagt aber vor.
History musste noch diplomatisch schreiben das ist sehr genau in dem buch geschildert.
Das ist eine echt gute idee passwörter veröffentlichen in büchern geil.
Ja aber das ist ein typisches hier geile story geiles passwort und so teuer.
Am ende war das so der typ hat das dann der journalist hat es geschafft die datei zu entschlüsseln aber die datei die da drin war war dann eine seven sip verschlüsselt komprimierter datei und das hat er dann nicht hingekriegt.
Und dann musst du das dann nochmal nach zum assange gefahren hat sich die datei dann irgendwie noch einpacken.
Super experten.
Ja tatsächlich experten tum und auch etwas naja was eben tatsächlich leider leider leider obwohl es eigentlich man würde erwarten.
Das zum journalistischen handwerkszeug gar nicht so viel gehört.
Das aber doch auf jeden fall mal ein paar dateien zu manövrieren zu können aber gehörte da offenbar nicht dazu okay wie.
Die kern oder einige der wichtigsten thesen die der fit jared vorträgt also der verteidiger von assange das.
Die fans statement also das was er dort vorgetragen hat glaube ich so achtundzwanzig seiten haben wir auch in den shownotes verlinkt da kann man sich das nochmal genau anschauen,
ich hab jetzt mal nur sieben in meinen augen ganz wichtige punkte daraus genommen sicherlich fehlt da noch auch einer aber er sagt also erstens.
Ist das hier eindeutig den politisch motiviertes verfahren und bei der auslieferung ist politischer verfolgung ausgeschlossen insofern bräuchte man das verfahren gar nicht zu führen,
zweitens sagt er dass es eine ausführliche überwachung,
der loyal clint kommunikation also der der anwalt der geschützten anwaltlichen kommunikation gibt und dass auch dokumentiert ist.
Insbesondere sie dazu den vortrag von andy müller macron beim sechsunddreißig drei wo.
Er im detail schildert wie eine spanisches unternehmen.
Wanzen angebracht hat überwachungskameras angebracht hat mit lasern versucht hat vibration von den fenstern abzutragen also die haben den assange einfach von vorne bis hinten in dieser,
botschaft überwacht ein eigentlich.
Unvorstellbarer vorgang ja also in der in der botschaft eines anderen landes überwachungsmaßnahmen durchführen noch dazu eben hier gegen jemanden der damit seine anwältin kommuniziert und so ja.
Weiterhin will die verteidigung im rahmen des verfahrens belege anbringen dass sie neben der,
also andere pläne der usa waren ihn zu entführen oder zu vergiften und dafür hätten sie belege dir dir anbringen möchte.
Und dann kommt aber der sehr wichtige punkt ich hatte ja gerade gesagt einmal diese veröffentlichung der namen und zweitens dieses dass er chelsea manning geholfen hätte einen computer zu knacken so und da sagt er.
Naja chelsea menning wurde von diesem vorwurf freigesprochen,
also chelsea menning in ihrem urteil in den usa was ja computer wurde noch nicht mal gepaddelt wir gerade gelernt haben selbst die wurde nicht dafür verurteilt im von einem militärgericht dass sie ein computer gehackt hätte
insofern wie soll der assange denn dafür verurteilt werden dass er sich mit ihr dazu verschworen hätte das zu tun.
Ja geile logik auf jeden fall na man könnte es ja immer noch sein so naja wir konnten es ihr zwar nicht nachweisen aber es heißt ja noch lange nicht dass es nicht passiert ist.
Ja so ungefähr genau.
Noch dazu selbst die beweise die sie für diese konspirativ computers anbringen das ist ja nur so ein.
Chat lok.
Dass sie von computer haben und da hört es ja auch auf also da sagt er ja nur so ich muss mal gucken ob wir da für rainbow tablets haben oder probier mal dieses oder jenes und
selbst aus diesem chat looks geht nicht hervor dass das auch tatsächlich geschehen sei also es ist alles äußerst äußerst dumm
na ja dann sagt er natürlich das kernargument diese namen um die es hier geht die wurden nicht initial von wikileaks veröffentlicht tatsächlich kannst du dir glaube ich heute noch den
unredigiert datensatz irgendwie bei crypton runterladen oder so und selbst wie heißt der nochmal young wer ist da mit vornamen der crypton macht.
Ja irgendwie.
So jan kann ja auch nicht mehr sein aber da kannst du jetzt heute noch problemlos runterladen und wikileaks hat.
John jan.
Johnny.
Wikileaks nachdem es irgendwie an anderen stellen veröffentlicht wurde und äh in der welt war dann hat wikileaks gesagt okay dann passen wir unseren teil jetzt auch an.
In meinen augen trotzdem unnötig.
Ziemlich offensichtlich erwartet ihn kein faires verfahren in den usa ja kann man von ausgehen und sein medizinischer zustand ist katastrophal suizid gefahr und so weiter.
Besonders nochmal hervorzuheben dass justines department unter obama hat zwanzig dreizehn genau wegen dieser sachen,
sich spezifisch entschieden keine verfolgung aufzunehmen also keine strafverfolgung aufzunehmen wegen des new york times problems.
Also die haben genau gesagt wenn wir haben nichts gegen den assange in der hand.
Was wir nicht auch der new york times vorwerfen müssten und weil das der fall ist können wir wegen dieser sache nicht gegen den assange vorgehen und.
Jetzt unter trump ist dieses problem aber offenbar auf einmal wird das jetzt anders bewertet aber das heißt natürlich nicht dass das vor einem gericht.
Anders zu bewerten wäre.
Na ja ich meine das findet die trump-regierung bestimmt richtig geil also so nach dem motto ach das können wir das müssen wir dann der new york times auch vorwerfen dann machen wir das doch dann einfach danach.
Genau.
Weißt du die logik wird dann einfach komplett umgedreht so aha guck mal ja ihr seid ja genauso böse wie den den wir jetzt hier gerade eingekerkert haben dann können wir euch doch am besten auch gleich noch alle ein,
oh mann.
Irgendwie ich stelle mir den trump wieder da sitzt du ich sehe ja keine probleme ich sehe nur lösungen.
Das ist allerdings das muss man eben wirklich zugute lassen er ist er hat hat's irgendwie mit dem optimismus aber auch irgendwo.
Ja also auf jeden fall sehr.
Also ich finde die argumentationslinie der verteidigung sehr viel irgendwie stichhaltiger als die der,
quasi des staates der hier für die auslieferung argumentiert,
es sei noch angemerkt eine an einer stelle haben sogar die amerikaner sich besonders spannend verhalten weil der assange wollte unbedingt aus diesem glas käfig raus ne und dann hat er gesagt hier ich möchte dir gerne raus und so mit meinem anwalt reden können und so.
Und dann hat die richterin gesagt ja nee weil dann kommst du ja quasi aus dem gefängnis raus.
Und deswegen müsstest du dafür eine kaution zahlen also du müsstest jeden ball zahlen,
kaution wir müssen sich quasi müssen ja eine cortions verfahren aufbürden damit du aus deinem glas gefängnis raus darfst,
und dann haben selbst die amerikanischen vertreter die da sitzen und zu sagen komm gib ihn mir her ja die die da nur lauern um den halt irgendwie in isolationshaft zu werfen ja.
Die haben gesagt also na ja wir haben jetzt schon öfter gesehen dass sie eigentlich kein problem ist wenn sich wenn sich ein angeklagter mal neben dem seinen anwalt setzt und so das könnten wir schon durchaus machen hat sich die richterin aber nicht von beeindrucken lassen.
United kingdom you going es ist wirklich total hardcore diese ganze angelsächsischen welt ist aus den fugen.
Das.
Kernproblem ist natürlich diese ganzen vorwürfe gegen assange die werden da natürlich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht verhandelt also für die auslieferung sind nach meinem verständnis natürlich nur relevant ist das.
Gleiche verfahren ist das gleiche vergehen strafbar auch in großbritannien.
Was war das andere prinzip wir haben's in der letzten sendung glaube ich nochmal vorgetragen muss auch bei uns man muss auch bei denen strafbar sein.
Und dafür irgendwie keine folter oder sonstiges drohen und das ist natürlich jetzt sehr bitter weil dann ein größerer teil der.
Der argumente hier jetzt noch gar nicht zum tragen kommen,
weil das eben für das auslieferungs verfahren keine rolle spielt weil das auslieferungs verfahren ja unter der annahme stattfindet das den in den in den usa ein faires verfahren erwarten würde und zu zu zu.
Argumentieren gerichtsstraße haltig dass das nicht der fall sein wird ist natürlich schwierig was glaubst du wie geht das aus.
Das ist wirklich schwierig einzuschätzen aber so auf dem,
die dinge könnten für assange derzeit kaum schlechter stehen also mit trump auf der einen seite und möchte gerne trump auf der anderen seite.
Sind natürlich die politischen rahmenbedingungen wirklich extrem schlecht dazu hat sich natürlich großbritannien sich auch nochmal ganz elegant im der potenziellen eu schelte entzogen durch den austritt.
Also da ist sozusagen auch nicht gerade mit besonders viel druck zu rechnen und da sie ja sowieso gerade in diesem wahnsinn dass sich
alles gegen sie verschworen hat denke ich mal dürfte es auch relativ wenig möglichkeiten geben hier diplomatisch in irgendeiner form
einfluss zu nehmen selbst also,
in der annahme dass das überhaupt stattfinden würde bin ich mir nämlich auch nicht so richtig so sicher was eigentlich die position europas an dieser stelle ist es gibt zwar jetzt vereinzelt leute die halt sagen ja hier geht ja gar nicht ja aber.
Machen wir uns nichts vor für europa hängt da jetzt erstmal an an seiner person nicht viel dran,
abgesehen von dem aufrecht erhalten der menschenrechte und so weiter aber das sehen wir ja jetzt auch gerade an unseren grenzen wieder dass das dann im zweifelsfall nicht ganz so relevant ist.
Schwierig also ich bin,
zu wenig zuhause in dem britischen rechtssystem das wird derzeit ordentlich gebeugt das merkt man ja auch schon,
wenn man sich hier diese diesen bericht anschaut man sozusagen einfach hier wird einfach die maximale,
der maximale betriebs modus quasi gewählt in den die gerichtsbarkeit da überhaupt haben kann mit diesem terror gefängnis et cetera und trennung und ja vor bald und ich meine vor allem weil irgendwie ja auch unterm strich nicht viel gegen ihn vorliegt,
ja das ist ja alles nur
mutmaßen drei ja hat vielleicht unter unter umständen online in einem chat mal fünf zeilen ausgetauscht irgendwie für ein vergehen was mit der anderen person auch nicht nachweisen konnten aha das ist alles dafür kommt man sozusagen heutzutage
in terror haft und terror und eigentlich geht es aber darum was was jemand zu zeigen im rahmen einer journalistischen,
arbeit die er nachweislich in kooperation mit guardian spiegel et cetera lief das ist dann sozusagen das eigentliche problem.
Total over the top aber jetzt total wohl living.
Also ich denke es steht außer frage dass hier halt ein exempel statuiert werden soll damit sowas in zukunft nicht mehr so einfach passiert.
Und ja,
ich denke wir müssen jetzt die augen der weltöffentlichkeit drauf so ist es sehr gut dass da diese beobachter sitzen und darüber schreiben und da gehört noch sehr viel mehr.
Aufmerksamkeit hin interessanterweise schreibt auch dieser der crack merry so ja hier ich habe mich da mal hingesetzt so aber das was ich hier schildere.
Wie es da abgeht der schreibt irgendwie keinen,
das lese ich nirgendwo anders warum schreibt er niemand drüber ja wird alles irgendwie so hingenommen also das was jetzt hier
eben das sind hoffmann und crack mary und einige weitere schildern das kannst du genauso gut was weiß ich in irgendeiner zeitung schreiben das darf das verfahren findet im,
hochsicherheitsgefängnis statt weil.
Weil die anklage weil's hier sich um staatsfeind handelt und
zweitens der hat mehrmals versucht oder mehrmals versucht aus diesem glas käfig rauszukommen die richterin hat ihm das natürlich,
nicht zugestanden das wäre,
de facto von der von der faktenlage das gleiche geschildert und wenn das jetzt in irgendeiner was weiß ich in irgendeinem in irgendeiner welt oder sowas stünde dann wird er jetzt auch keiner sitzen und das noch in frage stellen und insofern.
Muster eben diese gesamte aufmerksamkeit der medien und der der weltöffentlichkeit drauf wenn man dann auch irgendwo für ein faires verfahren sorgen möchte und es ist natürlich schon ziemlich,
besorgniserregend und ekelig das habe ich ja schon hier schon mehrmals kritisiert.
Dass gerade in einem solchen verfahren oder noch nicht einmal in einem solchen verfahren die sich zusammenreißen können die würde des rechtsstaats irgendwie zu wahren.
Ärgert mich dann wirklich sehr aber das habe ich letztes mal schon gesagt.
So richtig so dass du das sagst.
Es wird einige zeit dauern bis da die nächsten verhandlungstage kommen und wir bleiben da natürlich an dem thema dran.
Noch themen an denen wir noch dranbleiben müssen kleinkram.
Genau jetzt eigentlich kommen jetzt nur noch kurzmeldung aber davon relativ viele.
Wir haben heute als c eine kleine sachverständigen stellungnahme zur wahlbeeinflussung und meine meinungsmache,
verfasst für leute die länger schon hier beim logbuch netzpolitik zuhören ist da nicht unbedingt
viel neues drin aber es sei insbesondere nochmal an die zweihundertzweiundsiebzig erinnert als frank rieger hier zu gast war mit dem schönen titel alles z erfragen,
wo es um quasi diese strategie geht den.
Die menschen in unterschiedliche realitäten zu katapultieren und quasi in in in kompatiblen realitäten ja wo es wo es nicht mehr darum geht dass dass man über ein.
Zustand was weiß ich flüchtlingskrise.
Zwischen an der grenze zwischen griechenland und der türkei um jetzt ein tagesaktuelles beispiel zu nehmen wo man über.
Einen sachverhalt unterschiedlicher meinung ist wie zu reagieren ist und was das richtige sei aber zumindest,
eine gleiche auffassung hat von den fakten und sagt okay das sind so und so viele menschen die rechtslage ist so und so und die auslöser dafür sind folgende,
und hin zu einer welt zu führen in der sich die leute noch nicht einmal mehr über die fakten einig sind.
So dass natürlich sich am ende noch nicht mal mehr über,
also nicht mehr über den umgang mit der situation oder ist richtig oder falsch oder politische flügel oder sowas oder interpretation gestritten wird sondern ein schon quasi,
man gar nicht glaubt was die andere seite sagt und da haben wir ein bisschen zu geschrieben wie das funktioniert,
und das natürlich dabei die sozialen medien eine enorme rolle spielen wir dürfen bei allem theater um irgendwelche cambridge analytica oder social bots nicht vergessen dass,
das gezielte ansprechen unterschiedlicher zielgruppen und die auswahl dieser zielgruppen das ist das,
eine große milliardengeschäft modell des internets nicht also neben scheiße nach hause liefern ja aber uns ist als menschen irgendwie nicht viel mehr mit dem internet eingefallen als zielgerichtete werbung.
Und damit haben wir jetzt inzwischen ein facebook mit so und so viel milliarden nutzern die im prinzip ziehen zu jeder tages- und nachtzeit zum freien verkauf stehen,
und das ist der ursprung warum es warum solche strategien überhaupt funktionieren können.
Und da muss man sich natürlich mit auseinandersetzen was eben von diesem.
Geschäftsmodellen des profiling targeting und mike michael targeting zu halten ist so das finden wir alle immer schön und witzig solange sie immer das verkaufen von schuhen geht aber wenn es auf einmal um politische parteien geht dann hast du natürlich echt ein problem,
und eine transparenz eine umfassende transparenz verpflichtung wäre eigentlich das mindeste wenn es jetzt hier um politische werbung geht aber,
in letzter zeit insbesondere findet dieser teil ja auch in ihrem facetten statt ja und,
nicht es geht ja nicht immer nur um wahlen sondern eben um wirklich großangelegte manipulationen kampagnen und desinformationskampagne zum beispiel,
der neue gag scheint ja zu sein das,
der bernie sanders jetzt in kenntnis gesetzt wurde dass die us-geheimdienste davon ausgehen dass russland eine kampagne zu seinen gunsten plant.
Das ist wirklich ein geiler dog.
Ich finde ich halte es nicht für unwahrscheinlich ich halte es wirklich nicht für unwahrscheinlich weil.
Also was das was am meisten im interesse also gehen wir mal davon aus,
ich glaube tatsächlich dass russland sich denkt so ob jetzt der trump gewinnt oder wer kann uns eigentlich scheißegal sein hauptsache in den usa die beschäftigen sich weiter mit sich selber,
und haben irgendwelche verschwörungstheorien mit denen sich auseinandersetzen können und wenn jetzt der eindruck entsteht wir würden den senders unterstützen kann das.
Zur folge haben dass einige leute deswegen dem sanders nicht mehr vertrauen weil das rogers boy ist und deswegen der trump gewählt wird super.
Und wenn wir es schaffen dass der sanders gewählt wenn er gewählt wird können wir nachher sagen ja habt ihr nur gewählt weil wir euch dahin manipuliert haben so oder so haben wir haben wir quasi gewonnen ja also es,
old and bastelt russia unterstützt trump aber in wirklichkeit ist das ziel dieser.
Dieser strategien.
Dass niemand mehr die wahrheit kennt und dadurch wenn niemand mehr die wahrheit kennt und niemand mehr irgendjemandem vertraut und alles in zweifel gezogen wird dann kannst du auch deine demokratie nicht mehr aufrecht erhalten.
Ich meine können sie der hinsicht natürlich im prinzip dieses argument für jeden kandidaten bringen um sozusagen noch mehr durcheinander zu erzeugen,
ich meinte joke in bezug auf sanders weil,
ich nun wirklich nicht für jemanden halte der sozusagen die also in meinen augen im verdacht steht hier als kollaborateure als internationaler kollabo operateur aufzutreten.
Das mit sicherheit mit sicherheit nicht aber deine these ist natürlich richtig es ist ja die eigentliche zerstörung des diskurses die hier,
am anfang und auch am ende,
solcher liegst steht ja man trägt das halt einfach erstmal in die öffentlichkeit die öffentlichkeit zerfranst sich vollständig darüber und abgesehen davon dass es generell,
den diskurs und die ganze diskussion um kandidaten ansich durcheinander bringen kann das würde ja im prinzip mit jedem anderen kandidaten dann theoretisch auch so funktionieren setzen setzt es jetzt hier vielleicht stärker eben dann auch noch auf dieses moment dass man sagt,
okay bernie sanders ist sozusagen auch der kandidat der dann sozusagen nochmal
mehr die teilung des landes und dieses dieses rechts links des kurses noch weiter befördert
wenn gleich auch im anderen extrem und dann kann's russland eigentlich auch wiederum egal sein wer von den beiden jetzt gewinnt weil entweder sind es die linken die die rechten anstürmen oder die rechten die linken anstürmen läuft letzten endes für uns aus gleiche raus hauptsache sind ordentlich beschäftigt und wir lehnen uns mal zurück und machen weiter unser ding.
Also und wir stehen halt dem.
Relativ machtlos die als als demokratische gesellschaft diesen angriffen.
Gegenüber weil und da würde ich sagen wir erstens keinen sauberen umgang damit gefunden haben zweitens weil wir genug.
Korrupte personen und dreck anstecken haben um ernsthafte zweifel an der rechtsstaatlichkeit und an der wohl verfasstheit unserer demokratie zu sehen sie zum beispiel,
den umgang mit assange in diesem rechtsstaatlichen verfahren,
und was jetzt den digitalen anteil angeht ich kritisiere ja hier regelmäßig eine bildungspolitik die darin besteht die existenz des internets vor den kindern so lange wie möglich zu verheimlichen,
und statt sie zu einem,
informierten und kompetenten umgang mit diesem medium anzuleiten und da das nicht im also zwanzig zwanzig noch nicht sinnvoller teil.
Eines jeden lehrplans ist
musst du dich auch nicht wundern wenn die leute nachher vor ihrem computer sitzen und was weiß ich glaube angela merkel hätte die grenze aufgemacht oder so weil der da irgendwo auf instagram stand oder facebook oder wo auch immer,
und das etwas trauriger ist also,
wir haben unter diese stellungnahme mal frühere stellungnahmen zu den themen einfach verlinkt weil vieles was wir da schreiben wollten,
wir schon mal geschrieben haben,
also wir in dem fall frank rieger konstanze kurz erd- geist nexus und ich weil wir das haben wir schon erzählt und da haben wir damals schon nicht auf uns gehört ja also,
thema medienkompetenz haben wir viele
forderungen für die digitale bildung an schulen digitalpakt hessen überall hat kaos macht schule damals gesagt okay oder was heißt damals in den vergangenen jahren gesagt so und so müsste eine bildungspolitik stellungnahmen it-sicherheit haben wir x
vom recht auf verschlüsselung über,
das it-sicherheitsgesetz über wie man staatliche it-sicherheit fördern kann ja das alles immer wasser unter der brücke.
Integrität von wahlen setzt der c sich mit wahl computern seit wann war.
Da muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken wann das überhaupt war zweitausend,
sieben und bis hin zu jetzt pc wahl zweitausendsiebzehn zehn jahre später also über eine dekade setzen uns mit der mit der integrität von wahlsystem auseinander.
Und dann dürfen wir hier mal wieder im bundestag irgendwie was erzählen dann werden wir gefragt was sowohl empfehlen würden ja das gleiche was schon vor zehn jahren empfohlen haben schon sehr.
Traurig dass das so zu sehen.
Du wunderst dich warum die vorschläge vom c hier für unsere schulreform nicht angenommen werden doch ist doch klar.
Warum.
Bei der zfc natürlich von den russen unterstützt wird und damit bringst du doch dann hier irgendwie den kommunismus in schulsystem also ich bitte dich.
Achso ich dachte weil wir immer nur das gleiche labern.
Das könnte auch sein dass die schüler einfach was dagegen haben schon wieder die alten köpfe.
Ich zitiere da mal kurz also wir sagen ok transparenz anforderungen werden,
auf jeden fall so das mindeste müsst aber flankiert werden von hohen strafen für umgehung von transparenz anforderungen ähnlich wie das so mit wahlkampffinanzierung ist ne also du hast irgendwie,
wahlkampffinanzierung transparenz regeln und wenn du gegen die verstößt wird er da einfach teuer dann.
Strategie strategie der gegen propaganda befeuert nur diesen teufelskreis von zweifel und zerrüttet deswegen müssen informierter und umgekehrt informierter und aufgeklärter umgang mit sozialen medien.
Den kindern so früh wie möglich nahe gebracht werden und ja die infrastruktur auf open solide open-source lösungen umstellen.
Oft genug erzählt aber das kernproblem bleibt einfach dieses targeting und das ist irgendwie der große elefant im raum,
auf seinem zuckerberg den irgendwie,
niemand benennt ja also ich finde es interessant wie wir ewigkeiten uns den kopf über cambridge analytica zerbrechen deren auch das habe ich ja schon mehrmals gesagt,
primär deren primäres vergehen der verstoß gegen die agbs von facebook war dass sie sich diese daten geholt haben ohne dafür zu bezahlen.
Das ist das problem vor dem welche stehen.
Ja also bis man nicht wenn wir weitermachen sollen.
Naja wir haben diese stellungnahme abgegeben dass es irgendwie der ausschuss für fragen der europäischen union da gibt's jetzt wieder irgendwelche richtlinien oder was auch immer irgendwelche.
Also da wird jetzt da geht's jetzt kein direktes gesetz des ministeriums für wahrheit oder so insofern ist das jetzt auch nicht so.
Jetzt nicht davon auszugehen dass da jetzt so viel passieren wird.
Gut dann gehen wir nochmal zu verträglichen themen über.
Das leistungsschutzrecht das war sehr spannend ich habe zu einer der letzten sendung wo wir über das leistungsschutzrecht gesprochen haben.
Von einem jüngeren hörer also dienst jünger würde ich sagen eine e-mail bekommen.
Also noch nicht hört die sendung vielleicht noch nicht so lange eine eine mail bekommen ja sag mal das mit diesem leistungsschutzrecht das ja irgendwie komisch,
wer hindert denn,
google daran irgendwie solche leistungsschutzrecht behafteten dinge einfach nicht mehr zu verlinken und die antwort lautete naja eigentlich niemand aber die hoffnung.
Die also die die idee des leistungsschutzrecht ist ja folgende wir als verlage schreiben irgendwelche inhalte gut ähm.
Dadurch liefern wir eigentlich google auch inhalte für ihre suchmaschine.
Wenn es unsere wenn es keine inhalte im internet gäbe.
Könnte google kein geld mit einer suchmaschine verdienen deswegen möchten wir gerne dass google sein ganzes geld was sie verdienen die verdienen ja viel mehr obwohl sie keine inhalte ins internet machen.
Dass google für jedes mal wenn sie unsere inhalte auf ihrer suchmaschine.
Einblenden auch für kleinste inhalte und vorschauen bei uns geld geben müssen und damit.
Google uns das geld auch geben muss wollen wir google gleichzeitig vollzug zwingen.
Unsere inhalte du drin haben zu müssen denn eine suchmaschine darf ja nicht diskriminieren das ist tatsächlich die idee des leistungsschutzrechts es geht nicht darum dass google ernsthaft den.
Zeitungsverleger leserinnen wegnehmen würde weil die die nachrichten jetzt bei google lesen und nicht mehr auf was weiß ich spiegel de oder sowas ja sondern es geht darum.
Dass sie irgendwie ein weg brauchten um denen irgendwie geld wegnehmen zu können und das zu ihnen zu schanzen
und die hoffnung war eben zu sagen naja wir wenn wir erstmal das leistungsschutzrecht haben dann können wir gleichzeitig.
Google zwingen uns zu verlinken weil wenn sie uns rausnehmen würden sie uns ja diskriminieren und dann haben wir eine eine cashcow.
Jetzt gibt's aber den neuen.
Landet medienstaatsvertrag in der entwicklung wo auch gesagt wird klar suchmaschinen dürfen journalistisch gestaltete angebote nicht diskriminieren,
und dieser medienstaatsvertrag der länder soll im september in kraft treten und hat aber eine relativ breite ausnahme für das diskriminierungsverbot nämlich,
du also gemäß paragraph dürfen medieninteresse meditiere also das sind der suchmaschinen diese presseverlage inhalte nicht diskriminieren.
Wenn und es wäre also rechtswidrig das ohne sachlich gerechtfertigten grund.
Zu tun aber sie sagen solche so ein sack sachlich gerechtfertigt der grund wäre zum beispiel.
Wenn die suchmaschine aufgrund urheberrechts beziehungsweise leistungsschutzrecht regelungen diese inhalte nicht vergütungsfrage anzeigen darf oder kann.
Und das wäre dann quasi der der genickschutz für das leistungsschutzrecht wie er schon immer zu erwarten war weil natürlich kannst du nicht jemanden dazu zwingen zu sagen du musst das hier einblenden,
und,
wenn du das nicht tust du musst das hier einblenden und bezahlen und wenn du das nicht tust verstößt du das gegen diskriminierung gesetze da war immer völlig,
unsinnig davon auszugehen und genau das spiegelt jetzt dieser medienstaatsvertrag der länder mit anderen worten die vielen,
autorinnen und autoren aus den unterschiedlichen bundesländern die sich um diesen medienstaatsvertrag kümmern dürfen sich jetzt um sie auf sehr viel besuch von von irgendwelchen springer lobbyisten freuen die ihn dann nochmal ein lustiges liedchen singen,
aber im moment sieht es danach aus als wäre das dann auch endgültig vorbei mit diesem quatsch.
Es ist schon überhaupt abenteuerlich meine gut man hat schon pferde kotzen sehen sagt man glaube ich.
Direkt vor der apotheken umschau.
Dieses ganze leistungsschutzrecht ist schon so ein wirklich extrem hahn im büchner konstruktion um überhaupt irgendetwas zu schaffen was angeblich ein wert hat ja und dafür dann geld zu nehmen und es ist bisher,
alles nicht gelungen.
Ja also diese diese ganze idee von wir haben jetzt hier einen wert und und und nur darauf zu verlinken und sozusagen zu zitieren es ist sozusagen schon urheberrechts verletzungen etcetera vor allem.
Im im im im im angesicht der realität,
explizit immer wieder diese in die mitte gestellt in die mitte der diskussion gestellte suchmaschine von google google news,
die eigentliche quelle der links ist mit dem diese vertreter ihr geld machen also dass sie sich wirklich dahin stellen und sagen so ja das was uns hier wirklich die kunden zu treibt,
das muss auch noch dafür bezahlen dass es das tut das ist schon wirklich echt wirklich geil.
Und jetzt könnte es halt darauf hinauslaufen dass einfach am ende sie einfach komplett ignoriert werden.
Irgendwie echt sportlich aber das ganze halt könnte man könnte man belächeln wenn es nicht in diesem ganzen wege schon wieder so viel,
good und so viel startup potenzial auch zunichte gemacht hat also es gibt viele firmen viele leute die sich einfach aus diesem ganzen bereich einfach raushalten weil es mienenfeld ist,
und das ist nicht gut.
Ich habe ja gerade noch als beispiel spiegel genommen,
die haben ja jetzt dieses pur abo jetzt nochmal für werbefrei heit bezahlen weil selbst wenn irgendwie spiegel plus abonnent bist heißt es ja nicht dass sie die nicht trotzdem noch mit werbeträger vollballert und.
Damit sie dir einmalig dieses ding anzeigen können setze die irgendein cookie das scheint aber ein drittanbieter cookie zu sein so dass keiner meiner browser diesen cookies akzeptiert und ich kann mit keinem browser mehr spiegel online aufrufen
mit keinem meiner browser die ich habe weder auf mobilgerät noch aufm.
Auf dem laptop chrome firefox safari es geht alles nicht ja ich kann diese seite einfach nicht mehr besuchen.
Ja hier.
Und wenn wenn ich das geht so weit dass wenn ich auf dem hier auf dem handy mit einem twitter kleinen spiegel link kommt dann sagt man twitter klein diesen cookie nehme ich nicht und ich kann diese gesamte seite ist einfach nicht mehr aufrufbar.
Die müssen was tun das geht ja so nicht weiter.
Wollte ich nur kurz nochmal sagen weil ich war wie ihr wisst dass einige aus der redaktion hier zuhören also falls ihr euch wundert dass eure artikel nicht mehr gelesen werden die heute ändern eurem komischen cookie banner fest
das geht müsste anders machen.
Ich meine das dürfen sie aus ihren zahlen ja selber auch rauslesen wo die leute hängen bleiben ob sich am ende für sie mehr rentiert da die pur abos zu nehmen und auf den rest zu verzichten,
ist natürlich eine entscheidung weil man kann ja niemanden zwingen seine arbeit kostenlos machen.
Das moment mal nein nein nein.
Du hast bei denen das normale plus abo schöne gut sasse ich will hier ich bezahle euch geld mache ich habe ich keinen spiegel online plus-inhalte lesen was weiß ich so sind teilweise sogar interessant.
Jetzt das ist dort das ding ne ich bin zahlender kunde bei dem ich kann euch diese seite nicht mehr besuchen ich kann es nur noch mit der app machen und selbst als zahlender kunde muss müsste ich jetzt noch on top dieses pur abo haben.
Ach so ich dachte das ersetzt das irgendwie das andere.
Nein nein das ist neu da ist noch eine noch eine mark achtzig mehr und dann ist es weitgehend werbefrei,
so und um mir quasi und wenn ich dann sage nein ich möchte das pur aber nicht haben dann kriege ich quasi ein cookie der sagt okay dann kannst du werbung geben und er hat
dem tracking was die werbung macht zugestimmt und den cookie nimmt mein browser nicht an und keiner meiner systeme das muss irgendwie ganz verrückter cookie sein und,
deswegen kann ich keine inhalte mehr sehen weil ich immer nur noch sehr ey wenn du das mit werbung gucken willst ist in ordnung und du musst einmal zustimmen dass wir dir werbung anzeigen und diesen cookie kann ich nicht
kommen weil der irgendwie gegen gegen die guten sitten verstößt sodass keiner meiner browser bereit ist den anzunehmen.
Tschau okay.
So als zahlender kunde ich glaube ich muss mal ich werde ihnen sagen ich will mein geld zurück haben.
Naja egal wollte ich nur am rande erzählt haben wir haben auch auf twitter auch schon leute gesagt welchen welchen gucke ich einmalig annehmen muss oder so aber ich habe in gerade wenn man's hier sowas wie aus dem torhüter klein ich kann jetzt nicht irgendwie
in meinem twitter klein irgendwelche irgendwelche developer konsolen aufmachen irgendwelche cookies annehmen oder so.
Na gut unsere freunde von frag den start bräuchten mal kurz eure petition in einer unterschrift,
denn die haben,
mit ihren informationsfreiheit anfragen sich an frontex gewendet die grenzschutzagentur.
Der europäischen union sehr interessant gerade wieder in einsatz zu sehen und hat gesagt sag mal welche schiffe habt ihr denn da so im mittelmeer und.
Wie sieht's denn da so aus so was habt ihr da so na wie sieht's denn mit euren aktivitäten aus und,
frontex hat sich geweigert deren informationsfreiheit anfragen sich zu beugen oder den den folge zu leisten.
Also haben die frontex verklagt und dieses verfahren haben sie verloren.
Und damit sie jetzt also die haben das verfahren verloren jetzt hat frontex die quasi die rechnung geschickt.
Für das verlorene verfahren dreiundzwanzigtausend siebenhunderteinundachtzig euro für ihre anwälte die jetzt also innerhalb von zwei tagen von frag den staat bezahlt werden sollen.
Es ist aber eben sehr unüblich dass europäische öffentliche einrichtungen ihre ihre rechtsstreit.
Kosten in solchen fällen gegen ihre eigenen bürger quasi in rechnung stellen,
das recht dazu haben sie aber deswegen machen sie jetzt eine petition an der man sich beteiligen kann.
Dauert nur wenige sekunden,
man kann sich auch die rechnung anschauen die frontex gesendet hat und das ist natürlich deshalb so wichtig weil das nur noch mehr eben
dieses recht auf informationsfreiheit einschränkt wenn du nämlich wenn es quasi schule macht dass du nicht nur das prozesskostenrisiko für dich selber hast wenn du dich gegen solche gegen eine verweigerte informationsfreiheit anfrage wende sondern eben auch noch mit
unklaren kostenlosen
der beklagten öffentlichen institutionen konfrontiert wirst und das rodiert natürlich dann eben diese möglichkeit oder unterwandert eben oder schwächt den mut der menschen ihr recht auf informationsfreiheit wahrzunehmen und deswegen wäre das sehr schön,
wenn frontex hier von dieser forderung abstand nehmen möchte also beteiligt euch mal an dieser petition.
So dann gibt's corona virus ist natürlich das große das große thema herr je.
Die ersten ich habe gesehen in deutschland gezählt schon hamster kaufe soll ich was mitbringen.
Prenzlauer berg ist schon leer gekauft.
Echt es ist schon leer gekauft wirklich.
Naja also es gab wohl tatsächlich bin jetzt nicht die ganze zeit durch die supermärkte geläuft und also ist jetzt noch nicht nicht so dass alle regale leer sind aber es wird von einem dreißig bis vierzig prozentigen gestiegenen umsatz der einzelhändler hier
berichtet also insbesondere supermärkte lebensmittelbereich das ist damit gemeint,
wobei die zulieferer meinten sie könnten den bedarf aber noch problemlos stellen aber ich stand auch so vor dem einen oder anderen ausgeräumte regal dachte mir so.
Ok ich meine da kann man da kann man jetzt natürlich drüber lachen aber,
vielleicht auch nicht also ich meine ich halte das in gewisser hinsicht auch für nachvollziehbar dass leute hier eine gewisse,
naja beunruhigung oder sagen wir mal vorsicht walten lassen
und sich einfach versuchen auf irgendwelche eventualitäten einzustellen ich meine hat man ja in italien jetzt gesehen wie es laufen kann und das will natürlich kinder haben.
Also,
mir scheint das irgendwie so ein bisschen so zu sein jetzt ne immer wenn wenn irgendwie die große panik ist dann fangen die leute auf einmal anzupreisen ja und dann
gilt irgendwie so die regel alles was die anderen treppen treppen sie uns weg
also treppen die so lange desinfektionsmittel in in irgendwie großhandels gebinden
bis bis in im krankenhaus auf einmal kein desinfektionsmittel mehr verfügbar ist da wo es gebraucht wird ich finde das ja völlig in ordnung.
Wenn die leute dann mal einen größeren einkauf machen oder so ne aber ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt,
mit diesem corona virus auch nicht den bedarf bei mir entdeckt dass ich jetzt irgendwie mir ein paar irgendwie mehrere kilo dosen mais in keller stellen muss weil ein paar ein paar jahre später wird der ganze scheiß wieder weggeworfen
also ich glaube nicht dass es zu einem nahrungsmittel versorgungsengpässe in deutschland kommen wird.
Nicht unbedingt einen nahrungsmittel versorgungsengpässe aber in dem moment wo dann halt wirklich eine quarantäne situation hergestellt werden würde dann würdest du ja auch vermeiden wollen groß einzukaufen.
Dann ist ja sozusagen auch der supermarkt als potenzieller wie ein umschlagsplatz auf einmal mitten im interesse und dann geht man halt lieber jetzt noch hin wo es,
zumindest noch so den eindruck hat dass es noch nicht so das problem ist darum geht's ja eher.
Also die videos die ich gesehen habe nicht aus wie leute die jetzt lieber schon zum super.
Eher aus wie leute die das letzte essen auf diesem planeten kaufen bevor es nur noch so einen.
Du weißt ja diese diese wir stürmen den aldi videos oder was.
Oder oder gab's da nur neue media.
Ich ich habe keine ahnung ob das ob das irgendwie aktuelle videos waren oder ob da nur irgendwelche hochsitz rausgezogen wurden deswegen äußere ich mich nicht dazu ja habe ich solche situationen bisher noch nicht gesehen.
Ja aber ich meine gut vorbereitet zu sein ist sicherlich kein fehler interessanterweise ist ja auch alles nicht neu und gab,
auch in deutschland vor einigen jahren nach diesen ganzen ersten saß und märz vivian dir,
da auch schon ein größeres bedroht szenario dargestellt haben potenzielles gab es dann wohl auch eine groß angelegte.
Übungen also der der der ganzen damit verbundenen epidemiologische
agenturen und ämter die da zum einsatz kommen also robert koch institut natürlich und wer auch immer damit noch dann in dem fall zusammenhängt,
und die haben sich dann eben auch ganz konkret mal so drauf eingestellt so ja was passiert denn
eigentlich kommen was soll eigentlich konkret passieren wenn jetzt so etwas nochmal kommt und der plan ist quasi in der schublade und das kann durchaus auch gezogen werden.
Ja aber das eigentlich spannende ist ja wie das corona virus nachdem es jetzt von der fledermaus,
auf den menschen übergesprungen ist ich glaube dass mit fehler muss es auch nach wie vor unsinn oder aber ok also vom tier auf den menschen übergesprungen ist muss das corona virus ja als nächstes.
Vom menschen auf den computer überspringen und deswegen wurde jetzt ein,
also es gibt natürlich jetzt schon die ersten schadsoftware kampagnen
die mit irgendwelchen corona virus schutz fehlung den leuten versuchen word-dokumente zu schicken die die makros beinhalten
und in der faz vom siebenundzwanzigsten februar wird der
leiter des gesundheitsamtes frankfurt zitiert er habe ein excel rechten programm um unterschiedlich schwere pandemien verläufe zu simulieren
ich stelle mir jetzt irgendwie so ein corona makro vor dass da irgendwo hinten frankfurt im gesundheitswesen.
Im gesundheitsamt durchgeführt wird und bin sehr gespannt ich habe da meine meinen humor drüber ausgedruckt und,
matthias schindler hat dann auch direkt anders gesund als amt der stadt frankfurt am main die informationsfreiheit anfrage gestellt,
können wir uns auf das makro des gesundheitsamtes in frankfurt freuen wenn wir wenn wir es dann irgendwann mal frei geklagt haben.
Ja ich freue mich auf das so das schlechteste tool dafür ist also warum warum sollte.
Nee eben deswegen will ich das halt auch haben.
Ciao.
Es wird auf jeden fall naja excel.
Hoffen wir mal dass das halt keine makro wie ein drin sind.
Da gehe ich halt von aus ich glaube das wird das erste virus was von der fledermaus über den menschen direkt in in die cloud hochgeladen wurde.
Ach mensch.
Na gut kommen wir jetzt mal zu den zu den wirklichen kurzen meldungen.
Das war jetzt alles nur das vorspiel.
Genau jetzt,
das war alles nur vorstellen wie jetzt geht's auf einmal ganz schnell die wir erinnern uns wir wollten eine wir haben uns gefreut dass es eine verkürzung der mindes-vertrag s laufzeiten in.
Mobilfunkverträge geben sollte stellt sich raus die cdu würde das sehr gerne jetzt blockieren und sperrt sich dagegen haben wir uns zu früh gefreut.
Zweite meldung aus dem mobilfunk die usa haben ja jetzt den,
secure trusted communications network act der aber eher bezeichnet wird als der rick and replays act also rausreißen und ersetzen,
indem sie sagen wir schmeißen und de.
Aus unserem mobilfunknetzen raus inklusive verbaute komponenten ausbauen und ersetzen und stellt sich raus dass gar nicht so billig deswegen.
Deswegen verheizen die jetzt das geld was sie eigentlich aus der breitband- forderung eingenommen haben.
Denn und sie nehmen jetzt eine milliarde us-dollar und geben die den ländlichen kleinen mobilfunkbetreibern damit die sich das leisten können weil
es gibt also den association also dem branchenverbänden der der ländlichen mobilfunkbetreiber wo also netzbetreiber mit weniger als zwei millionen kunden teilweise nur wenige tausend.
Vertreten sind und die sachen was anscheinend niemand in der verwaltung der regierung oder im kongress erkennt ist wie allgegenwärtig diese ausrüstung in unseren netzen ist wir können das gar nicht leisten deswegen dürfen jetzt ihre breitband förderung dafür ausgeben dass sie den ländlichen mobilfunknetzbetreiber bezahlen dass sie den guten scheiß rausreißen
und durch irgendwas anderes ersetzen stellt sich also raus ist gar nicht so billig hätte man hätte ich den auch vorher sagen können.
Naja was ist eine milliarde dollar also das ist ja nichts im vergleich zu der aufrechterhaltung einer überwachung struktur.
Ja genau dann kommen wir zum zum hacker bericht und zwar gibt es in.
Unglaublich vielen die weiß es ein fehler also ungefähr eine milliarde die nämlich einen broad com support,
board com oder press bastband haben für ihr wifi der.
Darin besteht dass der verschlüsselung den diese geräte auswählen am ende alles nullen sind.
Und das macht's relativ einfach den den traffic wieder zu entschlüsseln
unter bestimmten bedingungen und so gut wie jedes wlan gerät was wir kennen ist davon betroffen es gab aber jetzt patches dafür also wenn in letzter zeit irgendwelche patches für eure mobilfunk geräte kam für eure smartphones mit wlan,
dann sind die nicht schlecht die zu implementieren die umzusetzen genauso wie alle anderen auch.
Interessant wer solche wenn solche fehler halt in hardware sind ich meine haben wir glaube ich auch ab und zu schon mal drüber gesprochen dass es sozusagen nicht,
immer so ohne weiteres
sich so leicht ändern lässt weil es ja nicht nur erstmal eine neue firmen wer für diese chips braucht sondern auch immer noch irgendwie eine
eine infrastruktur um diese firma dann auch in diese geräte reinzubekommen was mitnichten überall der fall ist.
Ja auf jeden fall also liebe die betroffenen geräte sind iphones ipads max amazon echos amazon kindle android-geräte raspberry pi drei router von asus und way,
und so weiter und die firma heißt presse und nicht surprise das war einfach nur in dem artikel den ich dazu gerade auf hatte offenbar falsch geschrieben ja.
Also viel spaß damit ihr erinnert euch,
dieses unternehmen das gesichtserkennung für sehr viele kunden primär lord bereitgestellt hat die wurden gehackt und ihre kunden liste ist unter anderem
öffentlich geworden und apple hat deren ios app aus ihrem dingen geworfen.
Aus dem app store rausgeschmissen.
Genau aus dem aus dem app store rausgeworfen und die kunden liste zirkuliert jetzt ja da gibt's natürlich auch nicht forces sachen drin unter anderem warm-up warum wir die sowas haben wahrscheinlich für
publikums überwachung bei den spielen oder sowas.
Ja alle wollen das haben das ist einfach mal die methode zuzuordnen wer war denn jetzt eigentlich da wer war nicht da so ich meine es ist ja die kerninformation die man eben auch aus diesem ganzen anderen ist beim werbestrecken und so weiter benutzen wir mal einfach nur kamera draufhalten muss man stell dir mal so ein mäßiges ist glaube ich so ein so ein
haus woll mal so ein großer supermarkt so jetzt hältst du einfach mal meine was ja sowieso schon überall die kameras
so jetzt einfach in jeder tür kamera an person kommt rein wird erkannt weil,
jeder ist jetzt erkennbar ja und dann weißt du halt ganz genau wann kommt diese person zu welchen uhrzeiten wie oft bleibt wie lange,
und im idealfall über die zusammenrechnen dann noch mit kreditkarten etcetera weiß dann halt auch und wann wird was welches produkt wie gekauft das sind genau die daten die alle mal haben wollen und dann geht es halt wunderbar darüber.
Eine autorin von weiß dot com hatten bei denen mal irgendwie nach dem,
datenschutzrecht ihre daten angefragt und die hat eine liste an bildern und accounts bekommen insofern ja das ist wahrscheinlich also gerade dieses linken zu den accounts wenn sie dann irgendwie wissen okay wir haben.
Über facebook diese und jeden personen die werbung eingetrichtert die sind jetzt auch tatsächlich da ja das scheint tatsächlich.
Ziemlich übel zu sein ja geiles unternehmen kann man kann man sich echt ja.
Also das ist auch nochmal verlinkt.
Leider ist es wahrscheinlich noch nicht genug karma die brauchen noch ein bisschen mehr und dann gab's noch eine sehr lustige meldung auch in deutschland aus der gesichtserkennung gesichtserkennung,
glaube ich ohnehin dass wirklich zentrale große thema der nächsten jahre.
Weil es eben diese diesen link zur,
zwischen online und offline welt so ermöglicht und vor allem die die verdattert und des tracking.
Von personen auch in dieser in dieser materiellen welt in die wir manchmal nochmal hinein müssen um ein paar hamsterkäfig zu erledigen.
Am vierundzwanzigsten januar wurde darüber berichtet in der tagesschau und,
die tagesschau hatte als quasi als bild auf der videoleinwand ein bild von martin bär dass da irgendwie,
ewigkeiten gezeigt wird ja über die verschobenen pläne des innenministeriums zu gesichtserkennung logbuch netzpolitik berichtete so und.
Jetzt ist der martin berger martin ein filmproduzent oder regisseur der auch den film der illegale film gemacht hat der in unseren kreisen auch schon das ein oder andere mal empfohlen wurde so und der war eigentlich bei diesem,
er war einer von den dreihundert probanden die bei diesem feldversuch am südkreuz mitgemacht haben und.
Im zweifelsfall im rahmen seines interesses an bildern kameras und überwachung was jetzt auch in diesem der illegale film eben auch eine rolle spielt ja,
er wollte dann für seinen film da oder auch für ein filmprojekt dort drehen.
Und hat gesagt er würde gerne jetzt irgendwie den bildschirm abfilmen mit seinem eigenen foto und dann haben,
wurde ihm gesagt nee das dürfte ja nicht filmen darf sich ja quasi nicht selber von diesem bildschirm abfilmen weil nicht einmal andere bundespolizisten sein bild da sehen dürfen so toller datenschutz ist da gewesen dass er am ende von seiner teilnahme überhaupt nichts hatte
weil er eben dort nichts filmen durfte.
Und sagt eben absolut absurd dabei ich komme mit meinem gesicht der gesichtserkennung teil und darf nicht mal mein eigenes gesicht filmen so also fragt er bei der tagesschau sommerleute wart ihr denn mein bild daher die tagesschau sagt wir haben das von der dpa,
die fdp sagt ja wir hatten eine fotografin bei dem pressetermin,
die hat keine einschränkungen von der bundespolizei erhalten also ist das unser bild und wir durften das weil das feiern pressetermin der bundespolizei und die haben uns nichts gesagt und die polizei sagt,
sie hätte möglich darauf hingewiesen.
Keiner ist schuld und sein bild ist irgendwie bei der dpa wo es dann die tagesschau gekauft hat am ende der martin berg kann sich jetzt irgendwie immer nochmal ein bisschen publicity freuen.
Aber das zeigt schon dass da halt von vorne bis hinten einfach leute auch mit diesen sachen agieren die wirklich wirklich nicht verstehen,
wie diese technologien funktionieren und was das bedeutet wenn diese daten,
vernetzt werden und wie einfach die dann erkennbar sind dass es auch wieder so eine gefälle technologie ist ne die halt ein zu einem machtgefälle führt.
Naja so eine große gesichtserkennung datenbank die werden halt am ende auch nur wenige haben.
Auch mal gucken es wird bestimmt nicht lange dauern bis sie liegt so die haben dann irgendwann auch wirklich alle.
Na da werde ich mir nicht so sicher weil an die also gut die eine die irgendwann alle haben werden ist die von den bundesdeutschen,
biometrischen fotos für pässe und personalausweise denn da wird ja eine zentrale datenbank angelegt und die ist jetzt inzwischen angelegt die werden vielleicht irgendwann alle haben aber hier sowas klavier musste ja facebook und instagram scripten das ist alles nicht so einfach
und selbst wenn du diese bilder datenbank hast musst du ja immer noch die,
die zuordnung quasi dazu haben ja und ich weiß nicht das ist.
Das wird keine demokratisierte technologie sein genauso wie der demokratie jetzt technologie sein genauso wie der andere überwachungstechnologien ist am ende auch nicht ist.
Ja aber hast du nicht gerade darüber berichtet dass irgendwie einfach mal die komplette kleinen liste irgendwie schon abhanden gekommen ist es dauert ja nicht mehr lange bis sie ihre ganze datenbank auch noch irgendwo im internet auf dem webserver stehen lassen.
Aber das ist ja nicht das problem gelöst da geht's erst los.
Ja natürlich also du hast natürlich recht es ist es ist ganz fundamentales problem was da auf uns zuläuft und das hat mir in der letzten sendung auch schon,
gehabt deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich grundsätzlich einfach geboten für ein gesichtserkennung verboten es sei denn,
rechtssystem zu stimmen also grundsätzlich das erstmal zu untersagen und wenn es irgendwo erlaubt sein soll dann muss es quasi explizit genehmigt werden daraufhin gewesen werden etcetera p.
Da sind wir natürlich noch lange nicht.
Jut dann könnten wir jetzt aber immerhin am ende der sendung sein.
Und nochmal auf zwei termine aufmerksam machen allerdings erst im august aber wer weiß wie schnell hacker events heutzutage ausverkauft sind freut sich auf die frühen hinweise.
So sieht's aus.
Und es geht los im ende august am ende august vom zweiundzwanzigsten,
august bis dreiundzwanzigsten august an dem wochenende in der hochschule bonn rhein-sieg gibt es wieder eine weite iteration der frost korn der konferenz die sich ganz speziell der open source community,
widmet wo in zahlreichen vorträgen vorträge laufen über alle möglichen technologien und.
Und weiter geht es dann vom siebenundzwanzigsten bis dreißigsten achten in gifhorn,
dort findet das hacken open-air oder das hacken open air statt das ist feinstes hacker camping ausgerichtet vom hacker space stratum null.
Es geht um gemeinsames basteln diskutieren und grillen,
es wird auf einen organisiertes oder von zentral von den ausrichten organisiertes vortragsprogramm verzichtet stattdessen gibt es freiraum für selbstorganisierte vorträge.
Workshops wie gesagt in gifhorn.
In dem pfadfinder welfen hof fünfundzwanzig kilometer nördlich von braunschweig.
Tickets gibt's jetzt glaube ich auch schon bald zu kaufen ich gucke mal hier gerade bei presale also im moment ausverkauft warteliste ja.
Warum weiß man dann überhaupt.
Also lest euch das nochmal durch bestimmt gibt's dann nochmal bestimmt gibt es ja nochmal tickets.
So dann war's das oder.
Das war's aus der aus der traurigen welt des der netzpolitik,
in der nächsten sendung setzen wir uns dann mit ein paar anderen themen auseinander da wird's wahrscheinlich wieder um patientendaten geben denn gehen das ein thema was ich heute ein bisschen außen vor gelassen habe.
Dann wünsche ich euch noch eine schöne woche und sagen.